The sense of vision has long fascinated human
kind.
In the time of the Greeks, they believed that
vision was somewhat analogous to the sense
of touch. And what happened is when you open
your eyes and you looked at an object there
was some visual fire, some visual flux left
your eye, went out and touched the object
and the sense of vision was in fact the interaction
between this emanating flux and the object
itself. It was like a long distance sense
of touch.
Over time the modern interpretation of the
way vision works was developed, and certainly
by the Middle Ages I think, it was quite well
understood. And the way we understand today
is that a scene is illuminated by a light
source, in this case the sun. Rays of light
fall down onto objects and is reflected into
all sorts of different directions, and some
of those light rays are reflected into our
eye, where they are focused onto photoreceptors
and lead to some stimulation to the brain,
which we interpret as visual perception.